[Music]
just when you thought the Jurassic
franchise couldn't get any dumber
palek a sequel will show anyone still
cleaned to the course of the original
you ain't seen stupid yet back for more
huh Jurassic world fallen Kingdom
returned to Isla Nublar
isla Isla Iceland returned to dinosaur
Island a place two different
billionaires picked for their theme park
without caring that it was on top of a
volcano now after the original park was
destroyed and the park they rebuilt was
destroyed what's left of that Park will
be destroyed unless another billionaire
can build a new dinosaur island and
start the cycle all over again because
when it comes to Jurassic Park dumb
fines away
meet another flock of one-dimensional
morons some new some familiar like
Claire the caring animal activist
or Owen the cold-hearted mercenary blue
is alive you're just gonna let her die
oh yeah and if you're wondering why
their personality switched in between
films Hey look over there it's Jeff
Goldblum you like him right
thrill as these old favorites are joined
by all-new dinguses like weekly a
paramilitary guy to replace the last
paramilitary guy who replaced the last
paramilitary guys who replaced the last
paramilitary guy they see a half-baked
clone of all the other kids in the
franchise literally a loose collection
of nerd cliches and Ziya the spunky
paleo veterinarian who's never seen a
dinosaur before never thought I'd see
one in real life
wait really you studied I know medicine
while the park was open to the public
and not only have you never seen one you
never thought you'd see one what online
vet school affects you a degree
why bring you instead of a vet who
actually worked at the park and why did
this movie make a billion dollars but
look over there there's the car from the
first movie so I guess it's a wash watch
as the dinosaurs used to look at with
all in reverence get turned into Looney
Tunes
[Music]
led by another pointless hybrid the endo
Raptor
she's part Raptor and part indominus rex
which was also part Raptor
so now she's like even more parts Raptor
and she'll kill whoever you can point a
gun at and trying to respond to a pulse
coded laser targeting system but if
you're confused as to how that's more
efficient than just shooting someone
look it's an oil painting of John
Hammond does that still do it for you no
enjoy a feature-length homage to the
other week follow-up to a Jurassic Park
movie the lost world where an old cast
member gets summoned to the estate of an
ailing original Park founder then sent
to the island to save the dinosaurs only
to get double-crossed by a slimeball
junior exec who secretly hired a hunter
to bring the dinosaurs back to the
mainland for profit but while lost world
turned the third act into diet Godzilla
fallen kingdom limits all the action to
the inside of an old man's house and
then ends right when it gets interesting
remember the shot from the actual
trailer yeah this is really just a
trailer for the next movie inside this
movie so get ready to suspend your
disbelief and/or the flow of oxygen to
your brain for the best reason since
book of Henry for keeping Colin
Trevorrow 500 yards away from a Star
Wars script at all times and finally bid
farewell to your Jurassic Park fandom as
it slowly and painfully choked to death
by the smoldering ash of the thing you
once loved quick cut - the Brachiosaurus
from the first movie that's the same one
what is wrong with you people
starring red head redemption Indiana
groans and the temple of gloom won't
chronal is x-23 lured plot would of
devising ham billy quizboy Courage the
Cowardly dev it puts the Dinos in their
pen or else it gets the hose again fun
for the whole family
and 30 minutes of Goldblum's time 30
seconds of actual movie and 30% of the
misleading trailer the blend before time
I had to their life let me what a baby I
hear the Blues are calling toss salads
and scrambled eggs oh my and maybe I
seem a bit confused
well maybe but I got you pegged aha aha
but I don't know what to do with those
tossed salads and scrambled eggs they're
calling again
goodnight Seattle we love you